when faces you've seen countless times
become strangers again when you're
afraid to so much as blink lest you miss
a single moment that's when you know
you're witnessing an extraordinary
performance this year five actors lifted
the eight the lid of expectations so
here are the nominees for performance by
an actor in a leading role
Steve Carell Foxcatcher Bradley Cooper
American sniper
[Music]
[Applause]
Benedict Cumberbatch the imitation game
[Applause]
Michael Keaton Birdman or the unexpected
virtue of ignorance
[Applause]
Eddie Redmayne the theory of everything
[Applause]
okey-dokey smokey the Oscar goes to
Eddie right now
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you to the
Academy I don't think I'm capable of
articulating quite how I feel right now
please notice I am fully aware that I am
a lucky lucky man
this this Oscar this Oscar
this belongs to all of those people
around the world
battling LS it belongs it belongs to one
exceptional family Stephen Jane Jonathan
and the Hawking children and I will be
its custodian and I promise you I will
look after him
I will polish him I will answer his beck
and call
I will wait on him hand and foot but I I
would not be here were it not for an
extraordinary troupe of people my
staggering partner in crime Felicity
Jones
[Applause]
my ferocious and yet incredibly kind
director James Marsh
[Applause]
working title focus Lisa and Anthony
Nina and my ingenious team of Dallas
Josh Jean Jason Alana Karl Britney and
Carrie and pip now finally please this
is so extraordinary I just want to thank
my family and you Hannah my wife I love
you so much we have a new fella coming
to share our apartment thank you